it's a betrayal Republicans go ballistic
over bipartisan border bill they
demanded this is the game everybody who
knows anything about politics predicted
exactly this Biden comes out and says I
need a new law to secure the Border
Republicans and Democrats in the Senate
come together and create an amnesty bill
which codifies exactly what Biden is
already doing it's not it's there's no
negotiation here it literally just gives
Biden everything lock in nailed in bang
and so when House Republicans are like
yo no the media of course was always
going to say the Republicans are lying
obstructing and this was part of their
plan Donald Trump wants chaos this is
what they're saying they're saying that
the reason why in the house they're
they're they're calling this bill done a
Ral and they won't vote on it is because
they're terrified of Donald Trump and
Donald Trump wants chaos so he can win
the election it is the long con but
here's the reality we've we got this uh
post from Mike Lee US senator for Utah
who says the dirty dozen disasters in
the so-called border deal codifies Catch
and Release allows up to 1.8 million
illegal aliens to enter before temporary
closing off parts of the Border it funds
Sanctuary cities and NGO sending
illegals around the country it
subsidizes free taxpayer funded legal
council to
illegal to illegal aliens it expands
parole instead of limitting limiting it
it increases green cards by 50,000 per
year for 5 years work permit for adult
children of H1B Visa holders immediate
work permits to every illegal released
from custody after they pass an initial
screening nothing to deport illegals
Afghan adjustment act creates a pathway
decision for over 60,000 poorly vetted
Afghans who are brought to the country
due to Biden's disastrous withdrawal
weakens Asylum screenings by codifying
Biden policy no immediate funding for
the wall and now I love how Mike Le said
this is bad for the Border what it
doesn't mention is $60 billion in
funding for war in Ukraine or I believe
it's what 14 million for funding for
Israel 74 in total 74 billion in total
for between Ukraine and Israel so and
that's it's the whole bill is only 120
billion so I mean you're talking 20
billion for border and then it's it's
basically a war power bill zero Foreign
Wars funding zero dollars zero laws and
zero policy for border security well and
the craziest thing and Libby and I were
talking about this before the show
started uh if you read through the bill
and I I don't know why Mike Lee's not
bringing this up and other people but
there's there's a portion of this bill
there's a provision in this bill that
gives the the right for the all of these
things to be heard in the the DC
District Court going forward so that
that's right we found it yeah it's going
to give them they're on 150 yeah it's
going to give them where can i p I think
uh page 150 do a search for judicial
review it's right there at the bottom
page 150 all reviews on these matters
will go through the district court in in
DC in the District of Columbia so they
will have free reign over all of these
issues from now on in in DC the biggest
problem the biggest problem with the
bill the existence of the bill is the
Republicans allowing it to to be debated
is giving credibility to the argument
that there is a NE that the bill is
necessary in the first place the federal
government has all of the authority that
it needs to take care of the Border
there does not need to be another bill
there doesn't need to be new new
authorization from Congress there does
not need to be anything except for the
executive to use the powers that he has
and to handle the job given assigned to
him in the Constitution one of the few
things that are specifically said that
the president has to take care of I just
want to give a shout out I asked Libby
to tweet out the bill so I could pull up
the DC provision uh but Libby retweeted
Mike cernovich he said if the Border
Bill were truly a compromise Democrats
would support it as a standalone rather
than tie it to the $60 billion WTF to
money laundering Ukraine it's all about
money money laundering but uh I just I
just love the WTF like 60 billion it's a
it's it's done you it's it's over it's
it's remarkable that anyone in their
right mind could try to justify this
this expense well mean just send it to
you meanwhile Ukraine's like uh you know
forcibly enlisting females to fight
their War because they're doing so badly
they doing that it's at least a month
now yeah so they're they're forcibly
enlisting women to fight their War
because they're doing in Ukraine yeah
well women are already fighting in
Israel for sure that's like part of the
deal but the situation in in both Israel
and and in Ukraine is like these are
these are arguably existential threats
right so like if the Palestinians had
their way there wouldn't be an Israel
and if the if if Russia has its way they
might take you know at least half I me
can we can I can I point out that when I
said 14 billion to Israel that includes
to Palestine as well right we're funding
both sides of that war absolutely and we
have been for clowns like damn fools
we're dumb as I mean anybody
anybody who's watched our foreign policy
in the Middle East for the last I don't
know three four five decades knows that
we always fund both sides of every war
then we never
lose Schumer Schumer is saying the
children of of Gaza will starve and like
come on we all know when you send money
to these NOS it funnels up to Hamas as
soon as these resources go in Hamas is
the governing body they take it why why
are we playing this game and I'm not
saying like pick a side I'm saying
neither let's come back to America
baby the fact that we're talking about
it is so frustrating because there is
absolutely no legitimate reason for
Ukraine and Israeli funding to be tied
to controlling our own border it's so
godamn frustrating it just shows the LIE
right I mean it shows the lie so clearly
you don't care about American s you
don't care about American National
Security you really what they really
don't care about are Americans I mean
when I talk to liberals when I talk to
conservatives everyone's like yeah this
a little too much this whole immigration
thing is too much you have you have uh
officials in New York saying it's going
to destroy New York City and everyone's
like oh let's just do that anyway let's
destroy New York City let me let me read
this this page 150 of the bill it says
judicial review notwithstanding any
other provision of this act judicial
review of any decision or action in the
section shall be governed only by the
United States district court for the
District of Columbia which shall have
sole and original jurisdiction to here
challenges whether constitutional or
otherwise to the validity of this
section or any written policy directive
written policy guideline procedure or
implementation thereof issued by or
under the authority of the secretary to
implement this section long story short
you guys want to know what this bill is
it's a corporate it's trying to
corporatize the American government by
giving diplomatic control to the
federals it's not they're trying to make
sure that Donald Trump will have no no
power to do anything about the Border if
he becomes president they said
constitutional or otherwise meaning
we're going to do it whether it's
constitutional or not if we sign this
bill well and it's I mean listen I'm not
a lawyer let's let's shout out because
really really quick let's let's read
that again it literally says whether
constitutional or otherwise yes now I'm
not a lawyer and I'm not you know super
versed in legal leas but I I will say
that sounds to me like we're you know
giving full Reign to DC to make well
we're not to though is DC already has
full reain over a lot of stuff like we
already know that Biden didn't need a
border Bill to do anything he signed all
of this open border nonsense into
executive orders and various actions
within his first couple of days in
office you know that like huge numbers
of Border measures saying we're going to
increase the number of Asylum Seekers
we're going to let in we're going to
give everybody a court date we're going
to instead of remain in Mexico we have
remain in the US for as long as it takes
and now this border Bill what it really
does is it says we're going to get more
border agents to process more people
faster we're going to get more
immigration judges to give more people
Asylum faster there's nothing in there
the the record was 10,000 per day this
says if it reaches 8,500 per day then
we'll move the rest to a legal Port of
Entry what wait wait wait wait's no
they're not saying they're gonna stop
them they're saying after 8,500 the rest
can go apply at a legal Port of Entry
and it removes the requirement for
courts in many circumstances well and
you saw what Chris Murphy said right
Chris Murphy who's one of the uh
architects of the bill said that under
this bill the Border never closes he
said the Border never closes so what
kind of border security is this if we
can't even close our own borders well
here's the thing too so I don't know if
I don't know if you saw this but if you
saw this bill you'd be criticizing every
portion of this bill if it came across
your desk and you actually had the time
to read it
before but Matt Gates who you know for
all intents and purposes is a pretty
decent guy most of the time on some of
this stuff but he uh he came out and
said he he came out and he said uh uh
you know why don't we just defund you so
we can uh fund Israel I said I had I had
a post to him I said I said Matt you you
realize this this this isn't Israel
right we don't live in Israel You're the
America first guy what are you doing you
know um but yeah it's this this whole
bill is from front to back just terrible
there's nothing good in there we fund
the UN and the UN hires a bunch of
people that are linked to Hamas and
station and puts them in Gaza to
distribute all of the aid to Hamas but
but this is this is where we can find a
compromise how about we say all right 60
billion to Ukraine but no more funding
to the UN ever no funding to you know
this is the last one like you you you
you tie it to something what what what
did I say um the the general idea is you
tie it to Something in such a way that
it puts them in a position they can't
maintain we'll fund the fund the wars
that they want if we can bulldo all of
Washington DC listen 12% of the
population 12% okay if we can bulldo DC
I'm in uh no but 12% of the of the
population in the United States having
problem put food on the table today and
we're sending $60 billion to to Ukraine
why why it's it's this well because
chucker CH Lally it's money laundering
it is money laundering and like he
threatened that if we don't do it then
he's going to send our kids to go fight
in E everybody everybody that's in in
office now needs to get fired November
needs to be an absolute like it must be
a massacre everybody that's in office if
you're an incumbent metaphor m i wonder
I wonder who they got voting I mean you
know we're talking about the vote thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 800m and become a
member over at
timcast.net
time